The Marxists,
we're happy that religion had collapsed because they thought that that would
eliminate an entire strata of oppression.
And you can see that it's not like the Catholic church,
for example,
was free of corruption.
You know,
it was in many ways it corrupt enterprise and you could read it as solely a
corrupt enterprise.
And you know,
to hell with it,
it's good that it's gone.
And,
uh,
you know,
the Friday and it's basically thought the same way.
And so did most intellectuals,
Freud thought that religion was nothing than,
uh,
than a childish delusion that people
identified with because they were afraid of dying.
It was a,
you know,
it was a defense against death,
anxiety.
Look,
the Marxist argument and the,
and the Friday and argument,
those are bloody powerful arguments,
you know,
cause you can see it.
You do.
People use the religious belief as a defense against things.
They're too terrified to confront.
Well,
obviously,
you know,
there's the Churchill press,
people did it.
Oh,
press people,
get it.
Engage in,
you know,
conspiracies with people in power across centuries.
It's like,
obviously,
you know,
the question is,
well,
what do you make of that?
Well,
partly you make of it that all sorts of structures do that.
It's like structures do that and you know,
you can't just damn one structure and thanked the others are going to,
you know,
it's like the right wingers,
they're always owned about big government,
how terrible that isn't.
Left wingers are always on about how big corporations are terrible.
It's like,
well,
Bang is terrible.
It doesn't matter if it's government or corporations because things tend to tilt
towards corruption across time and then that has to be taken into account.
But anyway,
so the Friday ends and the intellectuals and the Marxists,
we're all pretty happy when the religious dream started to come apart and they
believe that the new edifice is that they were going to construct fascist and
communist would be so much better than what they replaced that,
you know,
everybody would be drowning in utopia and uh,
it's kind of too bad that isn't how it turned out,
but it's certainly not how it turned out.
How it turned out was,
hmm.
Sometimes when you tear something down,
even if you think it's terrible,
you end up constructing something on its ruins that makes the previous terrible
look like the work of rank amateurs.
And that's certainly what happened in the 20th century.
I mean,
no matter what you say about the Catholic Church and its basic barbarism,
especially when you know they were involved in the witch hunt in the middle
ages,
it's like those guys,
they were amateurs compared to the fascists and the communists.
You know,
they were counting their victims in the tens of thousands,
not the hundreds of millions.